China the country responsible for huge
technological advances and yet it still
can't seem to get pandas to china
is a gigantic and consequential country
where roughly one out of every five
people on earth live it is also the
place that trump has been ranting about
for years China is killing us what
China's doing to us is horrible China
cheats they devalue their currency we
can't continue to allow China to rape
our country and that's what they're
doing okay so even in the context of a
metaphor the word rape is pretty jarring
as verbs go it's not exactly bandied
about it's like if Trump said Congress
is really toe me on this border
wall the underlying point is clear what
he chose to express it that way is not
and yet for all that Trump talks about
China it seems that he's very much in
the process of learning about it just
watch what happened when microphones
picked up this exchange with China's
president during a state visit back in
November actually learned something
there rest assured the only thing you
took away from that conversation was
that Egypt is older and therefore less
though China okay great note to
self don't a t' too old but the
truth Erie's a lot of us are probably
under informed about China and that's
something that its leaders have
historically been absolutely fine with
Deng Xiaoping famous we had a lay low
International Strategy summed up by the
same hide your strength and bide your
time but in recent years there has been
a significant shift regarding that
because when China's current leader Xi
Jingping
assumed the highest office in the land
he said this kumoi shock and awe that
China needs to learn more about the
world the world also needs to learn more
about China you know what he's right we
probably should talk more about China we
should probably have talked more about
it on this show especially considering
we've done roughly 4,000 different
stories on New Zealand and multiple
pieces on
testicle receptacle from the 2005
Russell Crowe film Cinderella man so so
tonight tonight let's talk about China
and let's put America aside for most of
this piece and talk instead about China
on its own terms because it's been going
through seismic social economic and
political changes which have happened
head-spinning Lee quickly and many of
them Center on its leader Xi Jinping who
just recently tightened his grip on
power
the most dramatic political change in
China in decades a vote to scrap term
limits for China's president the move
clears the way for Xi Jinping to stay in
power indefinitely and possibly for life
of nearly three thousand ballots only
two voted against the unprecedented move
three thousand to two which means after
that vote there were two members of
Chinese Parliament thinking whoopsy you
really thought that would go the other
way maybe an edible arrangement will
smooth things over with the man who's
now emperor for life and that followed
on the heels of what was arguably an
even bigger change the fact that last
October
she's political doctrine known as Xi
Jinping thought was enshrined in the
party's constitution and that may not
sound like much to you but it's roughly
the equivalent of Donald Trump making
himself a founding father and including
Donald Trump thought into the
Constitution which would mean that
historians in the future would have to
pass the meaning of while Bette Midler
is an extremely unattractive woman I
refuse to say that because I always
insist on being politically correct
and she's consolidation of power has
been aided by the fact that unlike many
of his predecessors who tended to be
dull bureaucrats he's gone out of his
way to form a cult of personality about
himself for a time state media called
him she Dada or uncle she both of which
are objectively weird names for an adult
to call another another adult but
fantastic names for a pair of hairless
cats see Dada uncle she dinner's ready
creepy weirdos
and she carefully presents eight
man-of-the-people image his origin story
is famous in China are born into an
elite family his father fell from grace
and like many during Mao's Cultural
Revolution she was sent to work in a
rural village a place which has now
become a tourist trap the smartly
dressed tour guide shows us where she
slept an old picture on the wall we see
a well he helped dig and a sewing shop
he set up old farmers who knew she back
then still roam about these pseudo
mascots of this Bazaar theme park yeah
that is a bazaar theme park and I'll say
that knowing full well that this
country's most beloved theme park
features vomit-inducing teacups and a
massive pantsless sailor duck with no
genitals and she's branding isn't
confined to tourist attractions state
media has also featured folksy moments
like this video of him ordering pork
buns at a Beijing restaurant now that
visit was huge news in China and that
could be hard to believe because our
politicians eat junk food in front of us
all the time you can find photos of 12
of the last 12 presidents shoving ice
cream into their faces it's actually
legitimately challenging to find a
single photo of Obama where he is not
about to inhale half a pint of vanilla I
didn't even remember that he'd been
demolishing a waffle cone during the bin
Laden raise but clearly I'd remembered
it wrong I was wrong but but the reasons
for Xi's popularity go beyond marketing
himself as a cuddly XI data that you can
grab a pork bun with because for
starters he is riding an economic wave
that long precedes him over the last 30
years China's GDP growth has averaged
nearly 10 percent a year making it the
fastest sustained expansion by a major
economy in history which has enabled
more than 800 million people to lift
themselves out of poverty and many in
China's growing middle class are pretty
content with how things have been going
the tremendous public optimism is
striking everyone is doing better than
their parents did in their day I think
we'll be able to move to a bigger house
within the next 5 years and I expect my
life to improve a lot whatever happens
I'm very optimistic about the future Wow
a sense of optimism about the future
I've got a say as a British person I
just find that utterly incomprehensible
if you look up optimism in the OED and
this is true the definition simply reads
no so for many in China
things are going undeniably well but she
has even greater ambitions and I'd like
to focus on two massive signature
projects one global and one domestic
first there's his so-called belt and
road initiative a plan which is
absolutely gigantic in scope basically
involves China spending a trillion
dollars on infrastructure projects in
more than 60 countries things like ports
bridges and roads with the idea that it
could eventually span international land
and sea routes and reshape global trade
with China at its center to hear China
tell it it is the most ambitious
infrastructure project in modern history
they've even produced an
english-language propaganda video to
tell the whole world about it
[Music]
okay if I could just if I could just
interrupt this irritating Old Navy
commercial Hawking a trillion dollar
infrastructure plan I know I know that
you're probably thinking right now if I
have to listen to one more second of
that it's going to be stuck in my head
all week well just be thankful that you
haven't heard the rap break until now I
can't take it anymore
either they basically made communist
kars4kids that is too early to say
whether the belt and road is going to be
a success but she's second bold project
has already seen results because he's
undertaken a massive crackdown on
political corruption a long-standing
grievance among Chinese citizens it's
led to the investigation and punishment
of hundreds of thousands of government
officials some at the very top of the
party and this has been widely
celebrated with the state media even
producing a crackdown themed computer
game the People's Daily a Communist
Party mouthpiece released a computer
game where users can give electric
shocks to corrupt officials what could
possibly be sinister about being invited
to electrocute prisoners in a
government-issued game that is the most
entertaining way to package something
disturbing since FDR smash-hit board
game Candyland just kidding it's a
japanese-american internment camp and
this this is where we reach the point of
the story that you're kind of knew was
coming because so far everything that
I've shown you is what she data wants
you to know about China but there is a
lot of troubling stuff under the surface
for instance conveniently for she some
of those swept up in the corruption
purge were his political rivals and
those accused were often funneled into a
system that's been described as a
secretive extra legal process where
interrogators seek to extract
confessions sometimes through torture
and it's worth knowing that those term
limits that he successfully eliminated
were put in place for a pretty good
reason specifically to avoid another
maou under whose regime some horrific
things happened in China from a
collectivized farming attempt that was
responsible for at least 45 million
deaths - a Cultural Revolution that was
estimated to have killed at least
another million - his belief that this
swimsuit was flattering which I realize
now that I say out loud really doesn't
belong with the other two in that list
the point the point here is she is
actively removing the post male
guardrails that were put in place and
while China has never exactly been known
as a haven for free expression
he has clamped down noticeably on any
form of dissent whatsoever there is
dissent online and China's censors are
working hard to quash it they
temporarily ban the use of phrases such
as personality cult and my Emperor and
also references to Winnie the Pooh a
character long used to mock Xi Jinping
based on an apparent resemblance
apparently Xi Jinping is very sensitive
about his perceived resemblance to
Winnie the Pope and I'm not even sure
it's that strong a resemblance to be
honest but the fact he's annoyed about
it means people will never stop bringing
it up trust me she if your face even
remotely resembles that of a beloved
cartoon character the smart move here is
to lean in and backing down on Winnie
the Pooh comparisons
doesn't exactly project strength it
suggests a weird insecurity in him and
experts say that she is deeply concerned
the public opinion will turn on him
China's economy is already slowing and
she's reportedly haunted by the specters
of the Arab Spring and the Soviet
Union's collapse and that paranoia
may be why he's so anxious to
micromanage Chinese daily life the
government has a list of untrustworthy
people which can restrict citizens
ability to travel buy a house or take
out loans and over the next few years
there are plans to take things much
farther every Chinese citizen is being
assigned a social credit score a
fluctuating rating based on a range of
behaviors it's believed their community
service
buying Chinese made products can raise
your score fraud tax evasion and smoking
and non-smoking areas can drop it
if a score gets too low a person can be
banned from buying plane and train
tickets real estate cars and even
high-speed Internet yeah you could be
cut off from a high-speed Internet
although that could actually be a huge
opportunity for the finest purveyors of
shitty low-speed Internet
I'm talking of course about AT&T as of
this week our parent company so goodbye
everyone it's been fun it gets much much
darker here in fact she's crackdown on
human rights he's apparently the most
intense since Tiananmen Square and that
is not good because Tiananmen Square is
on the short list of places so infamous
you don't even need to describe what
happened like Chernobyl or Jonestown or
that one Cheesecake Factory we can't go
to anymore and she has intensified
government suppression of certain
religions in one province
Christians have been told to take down
the image of Jesus and Hank portraits of
she instead something I've also done by
the way so yeah I think it really ties
the room together it's a nice accent
piece and a Muslim population known as
we guys have been singled out for
dystopian levels of surveillance and
persecution here is one man talking
about a form that the government had him
fill out this piece of paper was sent to
everyone people had to fill it out
they asked things like if you are weaker
if you have a job if you have a passport
if you pray all these answers were
turned into a scoring system they would
categorize people into safe regular and
unsafe people that's pretty chilling cuz
generally speaking whenever people are
placed on lists it's not really turned
out well for anyone involved many of
history's greatest monsters put people
on lists Nixon the Nazis Santa all of
these animals did that I looked sure
enough if you are deemed unsafe for
whatever reason you're in big trouble
because China has incarcerated Muslims
in reeducation camps with as many as
800,000 individuals in facilities which
reportedly
to rewire the political thinking of
detainees arrays their Islamic beliefs
and reshape their very identities making
uncle Shi less like your fun uncle and
more like your creepy uncle who
imprisons 800,000 people in his
basements and if you want to see what it
looks like when she's jumping thought
gets put into Xi Jingping practice just
just take the story of Nobel Peace Prize
winner huge elbow he was imprisoned in
2009 for writing a pro-democracy
manifesto and last summer he died in
state custody and even China seemed
concerned about how that might look
fearing domestic backlash government
censors went to work social media post
mentioning Liu's name were deleted
online searches with his name were
blocked even simple candle emojis were
deemed illegal on some sites CNN signal
in China has been cut by government
censors every time we mention his name
exactly the Chinese media wouldn't allow
mentions of a Nobel Peace Prize winners
name which is a pretty intense level of
censorship but it's also my personal
policy towards Guatemalan activists
Rigoberta menchú do not bring her up
around me she knows what she did you
know what you did Rigoberta you know
what you did I don't hear our name on
your lips that's not what this meetings
about
but the point is what it is what
happened to you she'll bo and his wife
who is still under house arrest is
absolutely tragic although to his credit
he didn't go down without taking a final
swing one of the last known photos of
Lee you was with his wife Lucia at first
glance unremarkable but notice the mugs
they're holding yep
that's really the true
good for that chuckling I think deep
down we all know when you need to really
tell someone to go themselves
why not do it with a mark what the hope
the whole point here is under Xi
Jingping China is becoming more
authoritarian just as it has major plans
for expansion onto the world stage so
the era of hide and bide is over and the
era of do as we say may be dawning
because China has significant economic
leverage and it has been using that to
silence criticism even when criticism is
very much warranted the European Union
hardly squeaks about human rights
anymore or certainly the British don't
you don't get much on Tibet either
because whenever anyone raises any of
these issues China turns around and says
do you want to do business or not of
course because China knows no matter how
badly they behave the world will still
want to do business with them they're
like Facebook oh I'm sorry you don't
like us mining your data and
undercutting your democracy what exactly
are you gonna do about it
male people printed out photos of your
meals you ate call your friends and tell
them happy birthday and out loud words I
don't think so go yourself
here is where having set America aside
at the start we should bring it back in
because it is arguably more important
than ever than America be strategic and
tactical about how to deal with China
sadly those qualities are not hallmarks
of this guy who couldn't play chess for
longer than 29 seconds without screaming
my horse eats your big lady and pouring
nacho cheese all over the board
Trump is blowing up the traditional
alliances that have helped influence
Chinese behavior on important issues and
that has been great news for Xi Jinping
as has the fact that human rights don't
really seem to be a big trump priority
in fact just hours after the death of
you gel polo
even has it as his administration issued
condolences Trump himself said this
president she is a terrific guy I like
being with him a lot and he's a very
special person Wow
that was not the best time to give Xi
Jinping a pat on the back it's the
equivalent of saying how much you love
Kevin Spacey in American Beauty right
now first you shouldn't it was
objectively terrible and second you're
picking the worst possible time to bring
that up
the point is Trump is leaving a vacuum
on the world stage and China is more
than happy to fill it by telling the
world its story and leaving out some
very important details so for everyone's
benefit if they're going to send out
cuddly propaganda videos about Xi
Jinping at his achievements someone
might want to make a companion piece the
kind of rounds out the picture
[Music]
[Applause]
taina bandung now it's growing big enjoy
let's learn about it now in this
annoying hum they have a president so
call him uncle she bunny can with
you instead
[Music]
he'll add a shield for you
you
[Applause]